passa un ragazzo bellissimo questo
nuovissimo episodi baffo l'abbia fatto
anche questo episodio della beta prima
che finisse niente godetevi il video
buona visione il presidente ragazzi
abbiamo qua potete la porta becco siamo
già morti e va bene comunque
ma
mi sa che c'è un orda lauri di salea
laurentiis se c'è scritto
siamo stati io vado dentro ciao
mitico la ceco i coltelli loro successo
scendiamo amici artoni e stato forse
conto di miracle lane chiamatemi certo
come no
no no la di girati un attimo
[Applauso]
ma chi è che chi è che la fate poi di
colti mi avete sparato in bocca non
c'erano neanche di zombie madonna sera
per il gusto di farlo ma dopo 90 100 cd
la guarda quanta gente ci alle altre non
puoi vedere da qua ok alla cassetta
ancora in da house quali ho trovato un
po di roba avete un kit a tre monete qua
no
è che la brujita fresno a cena il botto
di avete un kit e attrezzi
ad antidolorifici
graziano aspettava croce ha trovato un
cose del nilo maionchi da trezzi e akita
trezzi ok o il barletta è una formazione
penso che schiaccia e spara raga male
tutti un kit niente
34 st trezzi terminati adesso macchiati
donna assassinata attraverso la webcam
da quello antibes attrezzi testa quante
cazzate
sai quanta gente c'era già una volta
andiamo andiamo portando una
facciamo anche un ultimo consiglio
deciderà quando questo dobbiamo
prestigiosi quali sono stati
ecco donna basta mettere il filo spinato
distruggi l'ultimo numero del mio primo
run e roulotte che non sparando niente è
la mia libera l'abbiamo liberata
tutto è caduto mio grosso
violati e ho fatto fuori locarno
abbiamo attaccato
il padre to one shot a in qualsiasi
punto del corpo e praga e spara un colpo
ogni sei anni orribili questa roba a
coop per lo scalo è buono paga con
l'adozione di cosentino anche il
paradiso sarà nostro volentieri
e non perché troveranno migliora
sostanzialmente perché comunque tutti
gli amici di squadra è nata anche
allertato qualcuno proprio realmente ha
afferrato mi è entrato qualcosa abruzzo
graziato un'accetta tempo oddio aiuto
[Musica]
ragazzi io non ho più vita ok è morto è
morto
la band alice una spallina dove è
arrivato un altro anno arrivato un altro
mi lamento dell'accordo
ma siamo arrivati alla fine via via via
via via
che il simbolino
la gente l'ha fatta peccato ci sono
come
allora
uscente devastanti appena ho sentito non
c'e la balconata
alexa modalità discoteca
fai da te sto vedendo una roba tenuto
prevedere ma va bene vedrai la figc
palazzi sono solo adesso ti prego
appestati devo guardare chi frega
bellissima
non avete libero su alexa il momento
internet e non più le un meccanico ciao
ragazzi ho visto una scena madonna che
arriva in cella nikic e che caricherà
caminada fermo
è stato bellissimo alegi leggi leggi
sotto che
lei pensa lo sapeste
qui tutto alzata sterline
sono gli estrattori sono sugli specchi
ma perché ma cos'è bellissimo ma cosa
come davvero
dove magari ti spaventa gli uccelli
grazie l'anti io non c'ero meno male che
c'è a proteggere stiamo togliendo
l'acqua dello zucchino adesso morto
porca [ __ ] arrivederci ragazzi inizia
la perdiamo se quello che siamo neppure
cosa perdiamo deliziamo
perdiamo
l'ora di
rivederlo mi sono già morto non hai
fatto neanche in tempo a dire ce la fai
vai alcatraz thailandia è tutto nelle
tue mani
bene all'amore
già vista su barun di farcela a iaia
forte
la stessa scena ma indietreggiato con
una coltellata c'è stato veramente
nazione tipo giudicata
però è ha funzionato effettivamente
grazie
prego grazie di dio
fa c'è un problema la campana di merda
adesso si mette a suonare una famiglia
di roma un'avventura cassa
non muore mai è impossibile ragazzi di
via po troppo fatto è stata una
[Risate]
partita fallita eravamo tutti gli stesi
morti le su delta di oliva peccato
perché promettevamo bene
era una bella line questi ragazzi è che
oggi questa è andato un po più da skip
rispetto ad allora è un gioco un po
complicato non abbiamo messo a
difficoltà più farmaci ecco almeno ci
giustifichiamo così vai con ragazzi
probabili sia piaciuto dare un momento
mi piace chi sky dal canale è come
sempre al prossimo vito ai ragazzi
[Musica]